نحن الان نتواجد هنا في مشروع بيت لاهيه
حيث قامت طائرات الاحتلال ليله امس
باستهداف مربع سكني بالكامل هنا طال عدد
من المنازل الماهوله بالسكان هنا في مشروع
بيت لاهيه مما ادى لوقوع عدد كبير من
الشهداء ومن الاصابات وما زال ايضا هناك
عدد من المفقودين تحت الركام الان طواقم
الدفاع المدني تحاول انتشال عدد من
الشهداء في هذا المكان كما نشاهد هنا حجم
هذا الدمار بعد قصف طائرات الاحتلال لهذه
المنازل بشكل مباشر وهي ماهوله بالسكان تم
اخراج
اي عدد من المواطنين وهم احياء ايضا مازال
البحث عن عدد كبير من المفقودين وحسب شهود
عيان هنا في المكان اكثر من 30 شهيد تحت
الركام حتى اللحظه لم تتمكن الطواقم من
الوصول اليهم احنا اخرجنا من هذا المكان
على على امتداد 30 متر ما يقارب خمس اشخاص
عائله مكونه من اب وامراه وافراد اولاده
طبعا البنايه عباره عن عمارتين موجودين ما
يقارب 30 او 40 شهيد في المكان هذا
وتفاجات ان عدد من اسرتي انا شخصيا موجوده
تحت الردم اللي انت شايفه امامك وغير
قادرين على انتشال اي احد و بعد محاولات
كثيره لعدم توفر المعدات في المكان سمعنا
الهواي مش عارفين ايش اللي صار اجينا نجري
لقينا دار ضمار ضمار 30 نفر 30 نفر اطفال
ونسوان ورضع واصغار وامنين في بيوتهم ما
شاف كل العماره كلها قلبت فوقهم لايش فش
شي نشاهد حجم هذا الدمار بعد قصف الاحتلال
مربع سكني بالكامل هنا في مشروع بيت لاهيه
لم تتمكن الطواقم طبيه من انتشال سوى خمس
افراد في هذه المنطقه ما زال هناك عدد
كبير تحت الركام لا يتوفر اي
امكانيات لانتشال اي منهم الان في عدد
كبير من الشهداء تحت انقاض هذه المنازل لم
نستطع القيام باي
جهد يحتاج الى اليات الى بواق الكباشات لم
نستطيع القيام بهذه المهمه واستكمالها لان
نحتاج الى اليات وكباش و واقر لاستخراج
جثامين الشهداء من تحت انقاض هذه المنازل
الناس قاعده امنه في دورها لا صاروخ ولا
تحدير ولا اي حاجه ضربوا
ال ضربوا المنطقه هذه كلها واستشهدوا
تقريبا حوالي فوق 30 نفر منهم اطفال ومنهم
نساء فاهم علي وطلعنا منهم شهداء وفي تحت
الرقام تقريبا فوق ال فوق ال 15 20 تقريبا
تحت الركام تقريبا صغار اطفال صغار امنين
قاعدين في
بيوتهم وهي اللي صار وحسبنا الله ونعم
الوكيل
احمدد
دفاع ه الدفاع المدني اذا حدا سمعني يعمل
حركه ولا
يحكي مجزره جديده يرتكبها الاحتلال هنا
بحق المواطنين الابرياء مما ادى لوقوع عدد
كبير من الشهداء وما زال هناك عدد من
المفقودين تحت ركام المنازل انس الشريف
الجزيره شمال
غزه